suppose i don't know i think uber is
done in california yeah because of the
the gig workers they're trying to like
democrats rights for gig workers and and
cancelling
people's jobs and livelihoods like first
it was the
the journalists right the freelance
writers and now it's uber and lyft
drivers people who are just trying to
make a little extra money on the weekend
and it's like
i what are you doing so this was a
democratic proposal
it's called assembly bill 5. it limits
gig workers
it was pushed heavily by unions and it
the journalists man when they started
freaking out i was right away i was like
i can't hire contractors in california
okay good good glad good to know i mean
you can but like
once or twice basically i think
journalists can only write 35 times
but some of these contractors have
multiple contracts
this makes sense like the way i explain
it is
let's say you like to pick up pieces of
wood
on the beach and whittle it into a
little a little boat
you did that work and then you say i say
to you i say lydia i have
this little tim this little man it's
adorable it's a little me yeah he's
really cool and i
i have made such art i would like to
sell it to you okay
and the state says you can't do that
because you're not an employee oh
that's what ab5 basically is doing now
if i write something
and want to sell it to a company i can't
now the state is telling me i can't
literally sell a good
it gets it gets complicated now when
when it comes to uber
the way uber and lyft essentially was
working was that you do your thing man
we'll just connect you with people right
well this is fantastic
a judge ruled that uber has to
have all the people be employees and so
i guess
uber said this right they were like yeah
i think it was super if you
don't rethink this california we will
shut down uber in the entire state
yep talk about a state with bad
leadership
burning itself to the ground i'm i'm i'm
i i was talking to a friend in la who
said
it's worse than it's ever been yeah to a
friend in fresno who said the exact same
thing garbage is everywhere
violence yeah you can witness anything
you like on your front you know your
front porch
there's no this brings me back to like
the media bias
i wonder like how many of you listening
or watching live in a rural area or a
suburban area
i'd be curious to know yeah because
we're in the suburbs
so we don't see what's going on in the
big cities no i mean we're not going to
go there
nope i'm good yeah i don't want to go
there
but i was i was i was reading an article
about new york for one
mass exodus the moving companies are
straight up like where it's moving day
and we're overwhelmed and overbooked to
move people out of new york city
yep but i was reading from other people
who said that the city really is barren
like manhattan especially
because there's no stores yeah and i'm
like i
i want to i kind of want to see it yeah
empty streets
well that would have been kind of i
would have been kind of like driving
across california with absolutely no one
else on the street it was surreal when
we were driving through la
the streets were open wide open
it was rush freaking hour it was 5 p.m
and there was
no one on the road and it was i felt
like it was in a zombie movie it was it
was so strange
then when i went to philly i went to
philly a couple weeks ago and i don't
know if it was because of coronavirus or
because philly's a dump
but there was garbage everywhere like it
was piled on the street corners i saw a
rat i saw my first rat in philadelphia i
was like this is wonderful i'm really
glad to be here this is very enriching
get out of the cities dude yeah like who
would stay there and we
and i walked past these really really
nice apartments i was like i wonder how
much these apartments cost to rent
because right in front of them whoops
bumped my bike
there's this huge like wall of garbage
and just
literally rats running through it and i
was like oh dude i would
never live here the rats can't get food
anymore because there's no scraps
that's right so they're coming out and
hunting during the day
i saw i read something about like
somebody getting getting chased by rats
i think
oh my gosh maybe this was not real i
hope not like you got it
yeah you got to google it fact check man
this one but i i remember seeing like a
tweet
where they were talking about how in all
of these cities because
because there's no food anymore the rats
are getting are starting to starve
so they're coming out desperate and
they're going on hunts in packs
yup did you see the rat war no yeah
there's like rat gang wars
because they fight over food that sounds
right remember the baboon gang war
yes it was baboons right yeah yeah
because there were no more tourists
yeah and they would flock out into the
street man
we've created like i don't know what do
you what do you call that
animal dystopia it's like we in
in in our wake as human civilization we
have created
dependent subclass like communities
pigeons and rats yeah these monkeys
overseas and
oh man you know what's always like kind
of tripped me out
pigeons are literally our garbage
turning into living things and flying
away
that is a horrible like if yeah yeah if
i told somebody like
in in america our garbage grows wings
and flies away
people would be like what are you
talking about here crazy a guy's walking
on the street he's got a cheeseburger in
his hand
and he slams it on the ground because
he's lazy and
right you know and now there's festering
food a pigeon swoops down they all eat
it
that food breaks it down in their
bellies turns into eggs and more pigeons
our garbage literally gets converted
into birds
and then our garbage flies away and then
comes back to pester us
i mean not really pigeons kind of well
they poop on stuff yeah but
have you ever seen a baby pigeon they're
so ugly you've never seen one have you
no well i haven't seen one
googled one yeah i did google one
because they're really freaking weird
looking
i i think it is a privilege i think it
is a privilege that our garbage flies
away
could you imagine if there were no pages
of garbage everywhere just rotting in
the streets that's true pigeons clean it
up and they leave
but yeah so now because there's no
people the pigeons are flying off
yeah that's easy for them right but the
rats have nowhere to go
they're coming out of the ground they're
coming out in packs you know what man we
can we can complain about antifa in the
far left all day night but you know what
really scare me
like if i see an antifa guy i know
there's certain limits
to what they've done what they can do if
i see a far right guy like i'll avoid
them both
i mean far right isn't like you know the
colloquial yeah like the real extremists
whatever if i see an extremist i don't
care what their political ideology is
i'll go the other way i'm in my own
business
i see a a large group of rats
like running around ravenous i'm running
full speed
yeah seriously cause you get bit you get
rabies yep i don't know all sorts of
illnesses
yeah what was it okay the bubonic plague
was carried by rats
well that was the fleas wasn't it yeah
so the fleas on the rats okay so
if you touch a rat obviously you're in
deep doo-doo but rabies man
i mean i don't want to end up like joe
jordan i was just gonna say you don't
get bitten by a bat
we're supposed to be the ones biting the
bats not vice versa that was a crazy
thing
did you guys see this joe jorgensen
she's a libertarian candidate she got
bit by a bat had to get a
uh to go get shots like a series of
shots yeah yeah
um i hope she's okay i really mean it i
mean this is like a crazy thing to
happen
i look you know when i see stories like
this i can't help but laugh yeah
at the absurdity of it don't you have to
wonder what she was doing to get bit by
a bat
like she wasn't exactly on stage like
ozzy osbourne trying to bite the bat and
the bat was just like oh my gosh i need
self-defense it was she was probably
just like i don't know cleaning her
attic or something
it was so weird to me i was like how do
you buy a bat that's
i've seen a bat one time out here uh-huh
so
uh we've got a deck like you can go on
and it's like you know it's elevated
and i've seen i've seen like they're
kind of weird when you see them i think
they're birds at first
but they fly weird of weird
and if they bite you you gotta get a you
gotta get a bunch of shots in your
stomach or something is that what
those are the rabies shots have you ever
seen that happen i have not seen that
happen
do you know how it works yeah so i
didn't work in a doctor's office
i would see the nurses administer some
of the shots i mean and you would go and
get
shots from the nurses charge nurse and
doctors who were there
but i never saw a rabies shot
administered some of them you got to get
in your butt
sounds horrible no not rabies rabies is
the stomach which
your stomach also awful we're like into
your stomach
like literally not like your belly organ
i think it's into the adipose tissue
there
as far as i know so your belly fat i
believe
fact check me on this one because i'm
glad we have these vaccines dude rabies
is scary
i am too people think it's like they
think it's like a zombie thing it's not
no that all that you can't swallow you
keep spitting you start convulsing
i think it dehydrates you really bad
yeah because you can't swallow yeah
and then you get foam foaming at the
mouth
you do not want to get back by a rat man
don't get bitten by a bat either
we'll turn you into a libertarian well
uh for most of you you probably know
we'll uh we'll we'll we'll mention this
uh
crowder got his money back he did yeah
this is really cool youtube will let
steven crowder
run ads after a year-long suspension for
harassment that's
i think that's bs i don't think he
actually got suspended for harassment
i i think they they said he's straight
he didn't break any rules didn't they
well the thing with carlos
right carlos mazza yeah is what they're
considering harassment
or whatever so it sounds like classic
youtube nonsense
i don't really know if it was actual
harassment or it's just youtube's
interpretation
you know i think i think they were like
we have no choice because of the media
wave
yeah to do something but don't worry
we'll figure it out well i remember
thinking at the time i was like there's
so much pressure on them to do
something kind of like they're trying to
exert pressure on facebook right now
they have to do something so they're
probably going to like suspend him or
whatever and they sure did for a whole
year
dude so why did they decide to give him
his ads back
they were always reviewing him that's my
time
my understanding is that he had to clean
up his act
there were certain things he couldn't
have on the show but they would
reinstate him
and it's because it's it it is
interesting he didn't break any rules
but they they were like it's a rock and
a hard place
yeah i think they should have stood firm
but there's always
there is a legitimate challenge when
like if if somebody came to me and said
we are going to shut down your entire
business completely
you know unless you do one small thing
you'll find a lot of people would say
yes to it like for me for instance
i won't say the name of the creepy
whistleblower guy because they'll delete
the stream instantly
and for me i have my line well we like
talking to people so we're not
well no no like i'll tell you what like
i cannot say someone's name
i'm like whatever right but like you
know when it came to
i did a segment on masks and like
hydroxychloroquine and stuff and i'm
like if they ban me they ban me like i
swear to god like i have my limits if
the news is legit and it's
certified and we've got doctors i'm
saying it you know what i mean
and maybe they'll give me the x but i
think what's happening is
youtube is saying listen man everybody
will lose their monetization in an ad
pocalypse
unless we do something so you can jump
on the grenade or
adpocalypse right and i think youtube
said
you know that's what we're gonna go for
i completely disagree with this with
doing these things
right i think you know there there are
lines and limits like if i don't say a
guy's name
i can still let you know that there is a
name you can't say you can google this
and it has to do with the cia
whistleblower
and ukraine and you know now you'll find
the person
and you can then invest it yourself if i
get myself banned i can't tell you that
however
i will never withhold vital and
important news
even if it means the end youtube
deciding i can sacrifice an individual
because we're scared for the collective
to me is is how you get to
authoritarianism
yeah so crowder who broke no rules gets
negatively impacted and i'm not okay
with that yeah what's that saying you
got to break a few eggs to make an
omelet
you're willing to sacrifice a few people
the the greater good
i what is it like uh deontological
philosophy versus
i think that's what it is but you run
into that right yeah like uh
um i think utilitarian is like the needs
of the many outweigh the needs of the
feud versus deontological where it's
like
you must protect the individual because
the indiv there is no collected without
an individual yeah i'm toward the end of
that
i think youtube was wrong in this i
think crowder broke no rules and they sh
and i would i would
if they came to me and said there's an
adpocalypse because of what crowder did
i be like well i don't do anything wrong
so that's your responsibility
and while you're gonna lose ad revenue
now i'd be like yeah that's that's
that's uh that's too bad isn't it
i would not support a negative action
against someone who did no wrong
to benefit myself youtube should have
absolutely stood their ground and said
he didn't break any rules sorry you're
stronger than youtube i think
they're being kind of weak hopefully
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8 pm if you
want to catch the full show tune in to
this channel subscribe
hit the like button or check us out on
itunes and spotify and we will soon have
this podcast up for free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you